[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig this is a very delightful
episode we have lauren
and jeremy from the salacious scandalous
and sex
positively educational podcast wild till
nine
you my name no lauren as lar diy you
might know jeremy
as the self-proclaimed boyfriend of
lauren we talk about
everything how they slid into various
dms to start dating
how they've met each other's parents
what it's like
living and working together after having
public relationships
and we talk about you know the the scary
c word
children all of it's here and this
lovely episode with lauren and jeremy on
not too deep enjoy
[Music]
lauren jeremy this is so exciting
thank you so much for being here on this
beautiful episode i can't wait to learn
so many dirty details about both of you
can't wait grace i was trying to
remember the last time that
i was on not too deep and yeah i think
like how
i want to say it's like five years ago i
don't think i lived in l.a
no and we had this set up in an office
space
on the east side and we were like please
come to this rickety office we swear
i was trying to piece together the
timeline and i was like okay i
definitely remember getting out of an
uber being like
oh my god where am i i am a scared
canadian in this land and i don't know
what's going on
well consider this basically um this is
like a redo because i feel like
five years uh a brand new person emerges
you know oh yeah i think it's going to
be very different now okay
first i want to start off usually for
people that have multifaceted
jobs careers personalities i ask them
like what their deal is but because you
guys
work together i would ask you to
describe each other's deal
for people that might not know you so
how do you describe jeremy
jeremy how do you describe lauren for
someone that has no idea who you are
um oh my god here go ahead babe go first
[Laughter]
outside of being in a i guess
quote-unquote internet person i would
say lauren
is the creative director of her own life
that she puts into a media form
wow that's a great promoter pitch mine
is not going to be that smooth and
concise
i can't wait yeah i'm really bad at
summarizing literally anything whether
it's a movie or my boyfriend it's not
gonna go well
um jeremy is the co-host of wild till
nine
um and a ex frat president
also acapella once on nbc
can we get to this decade wow no i'm
this is the highlight reel the highlight
reel oh so um ex frat president
x acapella competitive um national tv
singer situation
which takes us to 2013. now turned tech
salesperson oh
yeah it's just yeah it's just it's it's
like a goodie bag of different things
and i want to make sure i touch on all
of them
no that's great you guys gave us very
brief little wikipedia pages of each
other
and i appreciate that now uh of course
we have to know you guys are
in a relationship with each other you
have blossomed this podcast
out of this relationship with each other
i have to know and i'm sure you've
explained this a million times
how did you meet each other
again not great at summarizing stories
so fame take it away
this one you can work together on okay
okay okay let's start i'll i'll pick up
so we crossed paths it would have been
in 2016 i think okay or
17 or so either way so i was in another
relationship
jeremy was engaged to someone that was
uh spoiler alert not me
um and uh he which would have been weird
if it was you
that would have been a very unique
situation there's a follow-up question
for that
we are like mad that it's not me but
also mad that it
yeah yeah anyway um we got the kinks out
we got
things though so jeremy worked in music
tech and i don't know if you remember
when
um remember when the roast yourself
wraps were really popular
yeah so me being
the youtube pop star that i was my roast
yourself
jeremy's company was essentially the uh
tech platform that lets uh individual
independent artists like myself put
their music on spotify
and itunes et cetera so he was
essentially like my contact person at
this music tech company
my assistant and i spent like hours on
the phone with him
get like working out the uh the tech
side of like the music industry
and um yeah and then and then what
happened next
well yeah fast forward a few years no
longer engaged um
and i was in the middle of my full-on
just let's have sex with everything that
moves phase okay
and yeah we've all been through that it
happens when things move it turns you on
and what are you supposed to do you got
a pulse and you're yeah you graduated
college
we're good this is consensual great yeah
right exactly yeah yeah
i and i saw on the
infamous and worst dating app in the
world raya um
i saw her profile yeah right everyone's
like yeah that one
and um but no one of course ever meets
on raya that's that's not a thing so i
met my ex-boyfriend on raya it's okay
sometimes it does happen
yeah that's unheard of wow
yeah i had to sift through a lot of um
professional
skateboarders uh photographers
lots of djs and djs and lots of
ambiguous
texts uh something your brother yeah
ambiguous but like i knew i knew better
than to actually use the app so i then
went to instagram
found a very cute dog picture and just
slid right into the dms
which she promptly ignored for two weeks
i didn't ignore it i just didn't see it
there's a there's a big difference
between those two things
yeah i allegedly ignored but here's what
i know didn't get a dm
back got it okay didn't get a dm back um
and then i saw jeremy on
hinge and so you guys have spanned the
entire
dating websites eventually
i have her number like we had like it
didn't need to be this difficult
it did not need to be this difficult
yeah so when you slid into her dms you
recognize that this is a woman that
you've been talking to
in a different capacity you or did that
come later that you realize that you
guys have a connection
i know i realized it but like and maybe
it's because like i live
and we live in the like post as far as
i'm concerned like post like harvey
weinstein area
yeah you don't use a number you get at
work per person you just
don't there are too many guys that look
like
me that don't know where that line is
and so to me it's like i almost
i felt like i needed to get the number
again or that contact again you need to
earn the number
you do you can't just be like hey what's
up like no i mean if you
had texted me out of nowhere i would
have been like oh what the [ __ ] weird
this like
guy from like three years ago was
texting me i was like what this is
creepy but
i i slid into the dms on hinge
um with a show-stopping flirtatious
message
message um uh it went like this
simply hey friend
so immediately your friend zoned from
the start i was like wow i can't
wait for this i have no game i just want
to put that out there i have
zero like negative game it's endearing
right in hindsight i'm i'm glad i'm glad
you were being yourself it was authentic
truly truly
uh okay so then did you return that dm
i was shit-faced out with a buddy and
i went from hello to like dinner next
tuesday and like
three messages two two yeah i know it
was
i mean i was right for it you can't say
that i didn't know what i wanted
it was uh direct for sure it was
directed
yeah like i said i was in the cr i was
not looking for a relationship when she
was
hey friend right right i don't know what
i was looking for but it wasn't
relationships so it kind of caught me
off guard to a degree but also
oh [ __ ] it here we are here you are so
it worked out
but how how long into it before
the revelation that there was an
unanswered dm in your instagram
oh i think i said that immediately yeah
yeah said something immediately i think
probably that's probably better i feel
like it'd be more awkward if like into
three months into dating i was like oh
this is
awkward well so you guys talk very
openly on your podcast wild till nine
about dating about your previous
um adventures and misadventures
now when and i think you've talked a lot
about like going on dud
dates and things like that so when you
guys went into
your first date were there assumptions
already were there expectations that
were high
low no expectations
i had been single for about six seconds
um
so i i really had no expectations you
didn't mean like i was
just i had been on maybe three other
dates before
so i timed this really well because if
she had gone on maybe even two or three
more days she should have been like oh
[ __ ] that's available
[Laughter]
yeah you'll be my maybe uh i'll call you
back i
didn't even i didn't i knew nothing
again i slid in with hey friend
so like me getting back to the dating
there was there was no expectations no
nothing on my end
i um i got to be honest and like it's
kind of like the whole like premise of
our first episode
i just assumed she was just some nerdy
craft girl who
you know was going to be like i don't
know awkward as hell yeah you want to
see my craft
it was like half true but like i think
to a degree it's not that i set my
expectations low because obviously i was
very attracted
no no no no i want to be very clear he
set the expectations low
how about this i don't i can't exactly
remember what my initial
thought was going to be all i can
remember is how shocked i was
at how not boring and nerdy you were
do you feel the backwardness of this
compliment right now i mean
it's it's working its way up i can feel
it working its way up but
good because my back is tired of
shoveling
but sometimes it is fun to delight
someone especially when you have created
like an online persona for yourself
that you can be like i'm not what you
think i am get ready to meet
who i actually am that must be kind of
fun yeah i could only go up from the
expectation that jeremy and apparently
had for me well i guess and here's the
other
side of that and the reason that i don't
work in like anything that's like
tech related that touches talent is like
um
i have had a hundred experiences with
talent and
if if i've had 100 97 of them i feel
like i'm like oh my god how do you
organize your life you stress me out and
i guess all of the things that i
disliked about the stereotypical like
showing up late not caring about this
not understanding this
she do all of it i mean she was a
businesswoman from day one and i was
like
that's hot cool i mean but that's very
fun and then also
i wonder lauren if there's any um
nervousness about then knowing that he
had helped you with your rap
video in the past
that shining moment of my career you
know that that exists
like we've all participated in tags and
things online that we look back with
cringe
a little bit and so there's something
really endearing about knowing that that
very intimate part of you had already
been shared with this person
i don't think deering is quite the word
that i would pin to that
um but i mean i i i mean i i'm an open
book online
and uh yeah that that was uh yeah
no secrets to um to unveil when you've
already heard the roast yourself
exactly he knows everything about you
already right
um i'm curious and like so many of the
questions that i'm sure you guys get all
the time
are about the uh getting involved with
people that work online
because you are being yourself online
you're putting so much of your authentic
like
private life into the public what was
that like for you guys did you have a
lot of conversations
about like the boundaries between like
talking about your relationship at all
showing it
telling anyone about it um i mean i came
from a relationship
that was so publicly online
like daily vlogging type level of um
publicity and so when we started dating
i don't think we shared anything
publicly for the first
seven months or so six months maybe like
i kept it so i just been
put on blast so hard online and i had to
like really
reel it in and be like okay this is what
we're not gonna do i don't ever want to
get dragged into that again
um so let's do the total opposite and
then i feel like eventually at some
point um
i mean i would say like at a year's
point we were fully comfortable just
being like hello we are dating
well i i think it's important to like it
sucks
but when you go into relationship with
someone who is famous
and you are not it's like it is your job
to i guess
moderate the things that you would say
even if they're totally normal for you
to say it's like how is this going to be
perceived by the people that idolize her
and no is that fair no but like that
that's that's part of the game
you're not going to get into it unless
you're willing to play that and if
you're not
you're always going to be uncomfortable
by the fact well i didn't mean it like
this i didn't say it like that way
that's right it's 20 20 that's the way
the internet works right
yeah and it must have been i mean
because both of you are still involved
in entertainment and you kind of know
how the quote game
is played a little bit and i i think
it's really
respectable lauren to go the polar
opposite and like
protect your privacy a bit because you
know the internet's a
[ __ ] wild wild environment
have you given into your personal life
the whole thing's sucked out there
and it's hard to pull it back in um so
when you guys started to be
more public was there trepidation
what did it feel right is it something
you still
work on i mean i think it's impossible
to come from a relationship that i was
in that was
so heavily public right and that people
um you know had put on this pedestal of
like seeing this this
um not falsified relationship but
glorified relationship you know it's
like with the clickbait curated
yeah curate exact that's the perfect
word curated that's it and
so coming from that people
are um you know not always a huge fan of
change and jeremy being like a new man
in my life
people were not um i would say the vast
majority of people were
welcoming and i feel like as my audience
has kind of aged with me they're like
breakups happen [ __ ] happens people
don't stay together
and um you know i feel like it's hard to
drown out those like very very loud
angry fans well that's the issue
the 98 percent that are super nice yeah
or the quiet ones exactly
it's like yeah it takes a very special i
mean it's like when you have a a decent
experience at a burger joint you don't
go on yelp and say let me tell you just
how
much i love
it just took it just took time and i
think um
as we kind of dive into different
podcast topics as well too
like as people get to know jeremy and
they're like oh wait he's
not a bad guy like so the people that
went into it with like this big negative
mindset of being like oh my god like who
is this like he's an enemy of the fan
base like those people eventually either
unsubscribed and like see ya have a
great life
or they're like oh he's okay i mean if
anything i feel like i'm half the time
being like hey
we don't need to you don't need to
protect it's okay let's let's let them
say that that's okay she's like uh-uh
let's do this and i'm like yeah let's
just
it's okay everyone's protective of
everyone else the fan base is protected
by the equilibrium you're protecting of
your relationship
it's like that meme of like the three
spider-men all holding guns at each
other
like everyone everyone doesn't know how
to handle the situation
but i think you guys have handled it
really well i'm curious now you've gone
from
uh taking your time getting into this
relationship on your own
uh you know accord and then now you have
wild till nine
this very uh outspoken
podcast and so
i'm curious how did this idea how did
this podcast come to fruition
whose idea was it what was the
conversation like
in just deciding to do it
um so i think
it was initially my idea that i want to
start a podcast
um i just love the idea of having the
ability to do
long-form content where i could speak
candidly
um the last couple years have been a
massive transition period for my content
of being like okay
like yeah crafts ended up being family
friendly i didn't mean to pigeonhole
myself into kid's content
my last relationship like he also made
kids content
so i feel like the last two years i've
been digging myself out of
um kind of like the kids side of youtube
over to being like
hey i'm 27 i drink i have sex like my
life is
very right very very normal and so
the podcast is going to be irate oh no
donna
but a podcast was um for me i have so
many friends who have podcasts and they
love the experience
so much i was like this is the perfect
platform for me
to not have to transition my content you
know when you're starting something new
you have to start with the voice that
you're choosing and so obviously my
videos have
have transitioned over time to being
more authentically myself but a podcast
when you're starting something fresh
um i just have the ability to be like
hey like this is what it is
and i think we were at a bar last
christmas
and phoenix the phoenix yeah and we were
having a conversation i have um
quarterly career breakdowns and so this
is my
this was we were we were on track with
the breakdown
because it's like it's like the
discomfort you don't know what's wrong
it's not like when your dog you can't
really like hey
just talk to me what's going on i look
and i'm like ah
uh-huh here it comes it's about to hit
here for one soon actually
for sure for sure um and so it's a
conversation of being like
would you be comfortable essentially
like helping me have conversations
because
i i like i can't imagine having to talk
by myself for an
hour oh that's that's i just can't
imagine that
that absolutely right i don't know and i
just feel like our dynamic
is um pretty entertaining we're both
just such polar opposites
so humble that what we're pretty
entertaining no but we're entertaining
because like i'm a [ __ ] craft nerd
and you're like a sales frat person you
know what i mean like
i have not been in a fraternity for a
decade no but the dynamic the dynamic is
so
different than um i think what people
would expect maybe
from the outside and so anyways it
that's that's kind of how it started
and here we are and hear you not too
deep i mean especially
yeah and when you have a voice like that
that's meant to be
on podcasts and narrate everything it
seems like
an obvious choice for you guys uh
now was the initial idea well first of
all how do you describe the podcast that
you guys do for people that aren't aware
of it
go for it babe uh to me the the most
interesting part
about our podcast and why i think it's
interesting is i think we
both live reasonably interesting lives
not like post pandemic hard to say
i think we both live reasonably
interesting life but
i think the most important thing is that
like working in tech and working as a
youtuber
like more kids want to be a youtuber
than they do an astronaut and i think
tech to people in the midwest where i
came from anyway there's always this
like this idea of like whoa i don't even
know how i would get to that but that i
mean that's where all the money is and
everything
and it's not to say that no that no
that's true but
it's almost like take the veil off of it
we're just two people
and through our differences we have so
much
that we are alike and i think it's just
funny to get our very very different
perspectives that get to the same
end result in an hour format once a week
i think too
i've um i've always been really open
about mental health online and we've
done a few like mental health episodes
but i also think that like something
that i never really had growing up
was any kind of like sexual conversation
as well that was
more open and so like normalizing well i
mean my mother just found out i had sex
10 minutes ago
right donna so sorry so sorry to break
the news she can't wait to binge these
episodes of your guys's podcast this
holiday season and really
she's literally blocked she genuinely is
blocked on every account
oh that's great but but i just feel like
i as um like a teenager early 20s would
have
loved to listen to conversations um that
just normalized like
breakups emotional baggage mental health
um
you know any kind of relationship stuff
but just like millennial [ __ ] yes
that was just like a missing piece i
feel like in the conversations that i
had
um with the people that i was surrounded
with so just even like friends and
family and so i feel like there's just
um so much to offer in terms of being as
candid
and taking the veil off as possible yeah
i think that's great uh i'm all for sex
positive podcasts especially because it
helps you guys start to learn about each
other i'm sure in ways that
you might not have known about before oh
it's our weekly therapy session no doubt
there you go okay we're going to take a
quick break when we get back i have a
bunch more questions for you about the
podcast
i also want to know the highs and lows
of your uh
quarantine so we'll be right back with
more not too deep
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things
a big thank you for listening to the
podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank you and uh second thing if you
are enjoying yourself here in this not
too deep
world we've built and you'd like to
leave us a review that would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise maybe just good or
otherwise would be appreciated
other than that enjoy the podcast
okay so now the podcast you talk about
life you talk about business you talk
about
lots of lots of sex talk on the podcast
which is very fun and i think very
illuminating for an audience to listen
to
what's the biggest thing you've learned
maybe or the most surprising thing
you've learned about each other
in the episodes that you've done if
anything sticks out
oh oh i learned that um
um wait hang on i've got two things one
jeremy has this thing called ticker what
is it ticker tapping
ticker tape ticker tape yeah first off
this is
self diagnosed so every doctor this is
self diagnosed and also like
literally the most random [ __ ] you'll
ever hear jeremy has a thing called
ticker tape where he
spells as he speaks he spells out the
words
like projected into the world in his
brain
as he speaks i read them in my head and
i don't i've always obviously i realized
that that sounds exhausting
and i'm just so confused by it and like
i don't even remember how it came up but
i'm like
what the [ __ ] oh no because i was like i
was telling a story and i was right you
could see my
my yeah you're what you could see and i
i mean i
i guess i didn't really realize it but
like why do i keep doing that and then
we looked it up and it's
i guess some small weird thing that
people do so we're basically a science
doctor podcast at this point
yeah all we need are two uh
not professional mental health
professionals
the internet needs more of them yeah
anyone else needs some opinions
okay so that's one thing that you've
learned which is a very interesting
thing to learn
what was the other thing you said there
were two you know what i don't know if
anything can outshine the ticker tape go
ahead babe
oh you've taught me nothing really
no i um it's it's funny because i don't
think there's any like large big thing
i think to a degree it's the every week
doing like a little bit of just like
talking about things that i
it's like the little things and i wish i
could like sum it up in some package
that's
great for a little clip it's honestly
just like the the
therapeutic just talking at each other
and listening right
now there's stories too that we've
gotten into that probably would not have
come up
unless provoked by um a sex positive
podcast
true very true now okay i'm curious
because you guys have obviously
spent a lot of time with each other this
pandemic this past year
and you do the podcast on top of all of
that
what is your day-to-day life like with
each other
is there a routine do we have boundaries
how does this work for you guys
um i mean jeremy works like a nine to
five so
i kind of like he kind of [ __ ] off into
like his real person job
and i am i do my youtube person job
which i
i actually i think it's actually very
helpful that he works kind of a nine to
five because i try and um
confine myself ish to um like a regular
non-defined hours i would say that
there's a couple nap hours in there for
you but yeah yeah a couple hours in
there
it's a 4 p.m thing but i would say for
the most part we
have a oddly normal
nine to five ish schedule well i worked
from home i worked remote
prior to the pandemics right right i had
to set up my my like my headquarters is
in seattle
so got it it's a little bit um like we
almost
like set ourselves up as best we could
for what
actually happened wow by accident by
accident for sure
very cool now what are you guys watching
in pandemic
do we watch shows together do we watch
shows apart
um the only show that we watch apart is
bachelorette which is fine
it sounds fine it's totally fine
um and then oh my god we have we just
finished the undoing which we
loved yeah boys the boys the boys
queen's gambit loved queen's gambit
i'm currently re-watching new girl for
the fourteenth time shit's crazy
um we watched lovecraft country what
else
we have been just blaze i've been
burning through documentaries and
docu-series
uh if you if you like the undoing murder
on middle beach is great
on hbo that's all my list that's on my
list i heard the finale
oh my god i have so many questions but i
don't want to do spoilers no spoilers
it's really good it's four episodes so
you can watch all of it i had to watch
it weekly which was a pain in the ass
but
it's it's really great go ahead i forgot
our favorite ted lasso
screaming oh my god that was
that was the highlight of my 2020 was
ted lasso to me that is something like
the best
television i've seen in years yeah that
was yeah you know what 2020
needed ted lasso yeah yeah it's so sweet
i was caught off guard at how sweet it
was i think like
my sarcasm walls were really up when i
started watching it and i was like why
is this so sweet
i don't know how to feel about it yeah
and then they started doing karaoke in
that one scene i was like so this show's
just
sweet all the time i guess
it got me good it got me good um okay
dogs are involved in your world how was
the introduction of new boyfriend to dog
um well moose was the initial
um access to the most important
relationship yeah yeah
jeremy actually showed up to the first
date with a small
little gift bag of a dog toy for moose
[Laughter]
so affectionate and so sweet and so kind
showed up with a dog toy
which actually got him an invite back to
my house on the first night
whoa
[Music]
we're about to finish dinner and she was
like i mean like do you want to like
give it to him yourself and i was like
we did not have sex on the first date
but um
i i just thought you'd want to give them
to your dismay
but there was a much more intimate
interaction happening with the dog being
involved
i feel like right you guys passed a
level on the first date
all right you got to meet you got to
meet my son on the first date right
right also moose is just like he's a
person now you know like some dogs just
like have this like weird
sense of just like ah and i love you
kind of thing he would have loved
anything that moved for sure
but like i think me liking dogs and it
going well was just like
oh this is cute right right for sure
it's a big thing it's a big deal the dog
knows even if they seem to love everyone
um now what do you you guys mention on
your podcast so you hardly fight
which is congratulations beautiful thing
do we have pet peeves about each other
or we're gonna start oh my god let's go
let's go tell us when to go
okay let's do top two
pet peeves of the other person or just
like idiosyncrasies that you might never
have
this is so difficult for lauren i've got
like three lauren has like 300.
really okay let me just hear top two you
can do a third if it's a really
difficult thing to
to avoid you know what i actually am
running through all the possibilities
that jeremy's going to say about me
more than um because i'm messier between
the two of us i'm definitely more i'm
definitely more of a
crazy thing i'm kind of like a tornado
going through the house yeah yeah it's
it's not number two yeah it's not a good
look for me oh you know what just go
ahead then
so tornado through the house is your
number two what's your number one um
lauren has something that will
eventually transpire into fantastic
motherly tendencies
but lauren needs to know where everyone
in the house is at all times what time
they go to bed what time they wake up
what they're eating for dinner
all these little day i got in bed last
night like i just couldn't sleep it was
like four in the morning i got in bed
and she was like are you okay what time
where are you ben are you what's going
on i was like i'm good
because literally i know it's coming
it's like i'm walking into my mother's
house and i'm trying to like sneak in
because i'm a few minutes past curfew
well also like lauren will just like and
you can hear it every time she wakes up
it's not like a oh you're here it's
it's like she she you know like in the
matrix when they pull out
leo and he gets back to yeah
it's the gasp of like life every [ __ ]
time which is like
sometimes adorable and sometimes i'm
like it's fine go to bed go to bed
the tornado has woken up yeah i don't
know why i do that like sometimes i
don't remember that i do it too so it's
not like
out of any kind of like bad like i don't
know sometimes you've never remembered
that you do
literally everything i know that it
happened last night i remember i
remember that happened last night
um how fun how fun for everyone
um yeah like yeah future kids watch out
they'll be [ __ ] because i will
wake up with my um you'll have gps look
trackers on everybody everybody
she's got me tagged fine friends perfect
so jeremy's number one is his inability
for things to fully make it into the
dishwasher um
yeah they make it one to the sink to the
side of the counter
to the the the the island
vicinity of it's so close like
it is so close and i just don't
understand why i can't just
it just it's it's almost more work for
it to go into the sink and then have to
pick it up later and then pick it up
again and put it in the dishwasher just
straight straight the we sound like
we're a 95 year old what you're saying
is a lie
you are correct yeah yeah i get it yeah
no my boyfriend does the same thing
there are glasses
so close so close
and always new glasses never reusing a
glass
ever just down a new one okay okay okay
but that's the thing
sometimes like i'll grab my espresso cup
i know i'm gonna i'm gonna pound at
least four or five of them throughout
the day
a little water no no he leaves the
espresso
in the bottom of the cup like the last
little couple drops of it and then it
dries and gets crusty
and then we usually go through i'd say
three espresso glasses a day
right so the attention is like i'm gonna
put it by there not put it in the sink
because i'll use it again and then i
forget and
you know just neanderthal oh get another
one and yeah
it happens it's a it's a it's a common
thing
is what i'm learning so it definitely is
so that's number one
um number two is a a random habit that
he rips his socks off at
any time like it's like it's the most
sporadic thing and then
he leaves them there so like there could
be socks in the kitchen in the living
room on the stairs in his office in my
office
like it's such a weird tendency it's
just like surprise sock
drops
it looks like someone got like kidnapped
in a random spot
in your house and left the socks fine
leaving context
and the socks left behind yeah yeah
breadcrumbs yeah
that i mean that's great so is there a
third one or should we leave it at two
oh there's 300. i mean there's three out
of the 300.
i would say just like the general um
decrease
of iq when jeremy is in the vicinity of
the kitchen
of the kitchen
i've never met someone i've never met
someone who's so
intelligent and so useless in the
kitchen like whether it's unloading the
dishwasher
or again you know the fork making it all
the way or putting spaghetti into
boiling water if i'm like multitasking
like
the inability to function in the kitchen
is astounding
well it sounds cute and fun you guys
yeah
cute and fun next time i get like like
[ __ ] on for it why can't you
it's cute and fun and fun one time grace
said it was cute and fun
i suggested it could possibly be
something that's cute and fun
um okay what's holiday season like
for you guys this year because lauren i
assume you're a holiday person but maybe
no no no um i actually no we just i that
was uh
two days ago so we're good now okay
we originally were actually supposed to
have um
my parents and jeremy's mom meet this
christmas for the first time
which oh wow typically we would do just
like tour de la north america so we
would go
up to canada where my family is um moose
comes with us
fly down to chicago where jeremy's mom
is and then fly back
and so we did that last year um
and it was great yes we're like all
right round two and then obviously plans
change
everyone was going to come here um and
then just with the new
uh lockdown restrictions um it's mostly
it's mostly the canadian side my family
oh yeah yeah not able to come so
um just us this year
fun fun keeping it cute and keeping it
fun
cute and fun and like there's plenty of
time for our parents to meet and those
political fireworks to go off
we'll save it there you go there you go
um
okay i have to talk a little bit about
craftopia which congratulations
so cool so fun so thank you thank you
well i'm curious of both of your
experiences
one lauren you like working in and
creating this show
and two jeremy watching and supporting
lauren working and creating this show
what's that like for you guys
i mean oh my god it was like to think
that
i started off as like an internet craft
kid to
being able to executive produce and host
craftopia um on hbo max like
it genuinely is so zero to a hundred for
me that it's it's shocking
it is so shocking and we actually filmed
season two uh during
like a couple months ago wow that was a
whole experience on its own just because
of like the coveted precautions that you
have to take when i think it was a crew
of 150 people
holy [ __ ] so yeah it was a whole thing
we made it through everything was like
really safe and great
um but it was incredible i mean it is
a totally different world yeah i mean i
mean you know from doing um
e you know yeah yeah how many years ago
was that how many e was
years ago but same thing that it's like
a huge crew and there's a
new level of responsibility and uh a lot
of pressure
but it's also extremely cool and there's
nothing but gratitude so it's all these
emotions
in one like snow globe of the situation
yeah i would say that that uh sums it up
pretty well
i will say that like yeah it's like
being on a high
of opportunity while you're doing this
um i will say i've never been so
physically and emotionally exhausted
just from being on for so many hours so
season one we had kid contestants
and kids can only be on set for i think
it is eight hours or six hours a day
yeah so our days were very um
rigidly scheduled and then season two is
with adult crafters
um which totally elevates the entire
show like for sure
you can like you you can hurt their
feelings as adults you can
imagine feelings yeah that's awesome we
got to be a little sassier
and it was just you know a little more
fun um to be with the adults and uh
simon cowell with crafts right the
timing of crafts but that also meant
that like the days could be 18 hours and
we would do that five days a week and so
like i was
um i was a ghost of a human um
for two weeks so jeremy got to be just
just live by himself basically because i
was not physically
emotionally present in my my sack of
bones of a body
i mean uh me playing witness to one of
the many
great and amazing things that lauren
does is is basically part of the job in
this relationship so
yeah i i stood in the front row with my
popcorn and said you should do it
i'll be over here uh yeah i i i mean
like the
like recurring joke is like every single
headline about our podcast is always
just like
lord diy and boyfriend and boyfriend and
boyfriend and i'm like you know and like
yeah either
like you have to like get upset about it
every single time you see it which i
think is ridiculous
yeah i just understand the fact that
like she's gonna do so many like amazing
things
grab a seat get your popcorn hang out
for the ride i wanna i wanna mention
that he's not usually this complimentary
to me
when we're not on a podcast he's being
really [ __ ] nice
i'm gonna take it though keep it coming
let me try again keep it coming it sucks
just take a trip into the kitchen see
how close the glasses are to the
dishwasher and then you'll get
steeped in the real jeremy now jeremy
what is uh
what's your relationship to crafts did
you ever expect
in your adult life that you would have
such a uh
your world would be so entwined with
with crafting
when i tell you i have the craft iq of
i don't know uh a two-year-old maybe i
actually i'm sure they're two-year-olds
that could outcraft me i mean if there's
one like course in elementary you know
they
made you do like all the different
courses whether you liked it or not
because you were just young and you did
what you were told
that was the one class that i was so
pitiful at
didn't enjoy couldn't stand i'm just so
bad at it my hands
don't do what i want them to do and my
handwriting to this day
still looks like you know that's pretty
good for a second grader
yeah you'll have to prove that i would
say the best metaphor for um
for this for this question would be
there was
um there was a time where jeremy and i
were simultaneously jeremy was
uh scrubbing the toilet and i was fixing
the dishwasher
and that's just that was that was an
accurate depiction of just like
the handy craftiness side of the
relationship and um
i'm vacuuming underneath the coaster
right back into the cushions yeah
i can fix the toilet and the dishwasher
yeah she's up here plumber's crack
fixing things
yeah perfect hey it works um okay we're
gonna take one last break when we get
back
i have a bunch of instagram questions
for you guys so we'll be right back with
more not too deep
[Music]
okay before we get into these instagram
questions i'm gonna ask you guys the two
questions i asked every single guest
that is on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most like to throw cold spaghetti
at yeah
[ __ ] donald trump
donald trump i think you could say
whatever you like to say that yeah yeah
of course that's a very popular answer
these days
spaghetti too trump said trump actually
probably hitler oh yeah yeah yeah that's
a very basically
related same category yeah yeah
yeah uh i'm with you two great answers
okay the other question i asked
everything
is it possible to maybe not do spaghetti
and like i don't know acid or something
else just like really i mean
yeah i don't think there's no world
where i feel bad about anything i throw
at adolf hitler
it's entirely your intention so you can
spike the spaghetti with whatever
just curious because this opportunity
will present
itself in real life one day and so you
should be prepared
okay the other question every single
guest is to tell us your worst pant
[ __ ] story
or a close call experience bathroom
experience
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases to describe the
experience
so for example mine is college jogging
front lawn um i just want to say that
i'm so glad this question is still
happening on your podcast
i have answered this question before
yeah um and my answer's still the same
i've never [ __ ] pants yeah hey it
happens i
envy you i admire that and i cannot wait
for the day it happens
you know what i will call you so we can
circle back on this question
specifically the day that it happens
jeremy if you have a story that you
could tell us in three words or three
small phrases
[ __ ] band camp oh
okay with the first word i
thought it was a different story
entirely but yeah
i was like wow that that's uh that's
rough
uh lots of things happening
lots of stuff happens in band camp so
i'm here
uh okay let's get into these instagram
questions for you guys
uh let's see ask them
what do you think you would be doing
with your life if you guys didn't meet
oh um so um
when i was freshly single before meeting
jeremy i was about to go
on a whole rampage oh um
so might might still be in that rampage
i don't know
could be could be i'd definitely still
be in the rampage
so you just have two parallel rampages
happening
yeah just just breaking your hearts
beautiful just ruining your own
self-esteem and breaking hearts
all the way great great okay someone
wants to know
do you guys have anything uh planned on
your podcast
i think meaning like do you have do you
want to do anything
any big plans for like segments ideas uh
stories that sort of stuff that you guys
want to go into
thank you viewer for that ridiculously
vague question
really i think i have three different
answers for this oh [ __ ] me go ahead
um i mean there's definitely a time and
a place for jeremy to
recap um his engagement hmm
oh so her plans are for me okay got it
yeah yeah i mean i
wasn't there wasn't involved so it's
like that's not my story to tell
um but also i think uh
i think why was it maybe that was the
only one i had planned
fine then i would love to have um unique
and fun and weird guests
yeah at some point and whether it's an
individual or a couple i think that'd be
fun
i'd love to do certain pop-ups smaller
like live recordings in front of like
smaller audiences
cool i would love to see yeah i think we
have a lot of plans like
post covet uh type type stuff like once
once we're able to be back in the world
that makes sense yeah with just like
guesting and potentially like like to do
anything at like a college would be so i
mostly just want to go to a frat party
in america like that seems like a fun
thing that i've never experienced
there you go i mean you can have a you
have an inn with a former frat boy
yeah yeah if somebody's been an attorney
like the moment you go into that party
you're gonna go
oh yeah i need to i need to experience
that moment for myself
they're sad and sticky that's how i
describe frat parties
when i told her that i had a pair of
party sperry's because
by the end of the night you're just
sitting in about two inches of just
like gross [ __ ] from the basement yeah
it's that you're gonna have to really
really wait till covet's over
before you like that sad and sticky yeah
okay um okay we have a ton of questions
about children
are there talks of oh my god uh
is this a potential podcast episode for
you guys
um children are definitely like long
long ways
down the uh the timeline for us yeah
2045
or or before 245 or before
okay okay my mom will not accept that
answer
wait okay i have a quick question about
moms so you guys have met each other's
parents
yes what was that experience like for
you guys
um so i did myself the disservice
of um portraying myself
as an angelic uh
clean-mouthed um just like
wifey material type of gal
yep and so um not that i'm not
maybe a small portion of those things
but so when i was envisioning what
christmas would look like this year with
both um
my parents and jeremy's mom in town like
my parents get the full package that
you're getting right now you know like
that they just they don't know who i am
and so i was trying to figure out where
the middle ground
of um this like uh very clean
persona that i had created for jeremy's
mother and by regular persona like
where the middle ground would be for
christmas
so anyway silver linings of not having
christmas together with the family
anymore
okay so you have still time to figure
out this middle ground
area yes i can assure you there will be
no figuring it out until the day it
happens
right now but but she very much
described me as a
delight and so i knew that i had
succeeded yeah so who's the salesperson
huh
it was me for donna it was me for donna
where's vice versa i'm over here talking
about my whole face on the podcast
yesterday's episode was all about my
like dui in high school and all the [ __ ]
that transpired so it's like
you what you've seen it's actually uh
it's better that now than it was so like
you can only go off from there right
that's great
very great okay um someone's asking for
you guys to describe each other's
aesthetic
in your own opinion oh aesthetic
huh interesting um
oh my god i don't even know what this
means like okay so like they are
aesthetic
like jeremy would be a
i feel like you're just like your
aesthetic is like tech guy
like you know like you you would fit in
in seattle
you wear a lot of lululemon oh okay
like lulu lulu men has some great stuff
and yeah they have great stuff yeah
i guess we love lemon lemonade yeah it
would be better if they would send me
some damn clothes yes there we go
um i would say uh tech tech man tech
businessman aesthetic with good hair
and fun socks um okay that works
with a little bit of dog hair and
glitter stuck to him wonderful
how did i do great i i mean you kind of
hit on mine as well but on the reverse i
mean your aesthetic is soft
or glittery um i don't i don't wear any
glitter though that's not like oh [ __ ]
yes not on purpose not literally not on
purpose but nobody wears glitter on
purpose yet i'm still covered
that's actually not not true some people
do make every single time i have a black
suit ever it's just like
glitter everywhere i take the dry
cleaner and he's like
so did you did you rave again well what
is this right right now you do better
than that
glittery i don't know if i agree with
that but fine
well the question was right now we're
supposed to describe the other ones
right
right so i don't know if i agree with it
but fine
uh a lot of questions about uh
do you feel weird that you've had past
relationships being on youtube
uh i guess this is a question for both
of us right yeah i think it's more of a
there's been questions for kind of both
of you about how is it being with each
other and
i like my current boyfriend has had like
previous relationships i've had previous
relationships
i think it's been for me a little bit
helpful like kind of uh
added like we get where each other
coming from kind of situation
i'm curious what your guys's experience
of that was like
yeah i mean i think coming from every
relationship whether it was online or
off um you know you come out of it
knowing a little more understanding a
little better how to be a better partner
and what you need in a partner as well
yeah um yeah i think from the online
perspective definitely learned what i
didn't want to do in the public eye and
so even though we are so like
graphically candid
on the podcast i still feel like that is
such a different level
of having a quote-unquote public
relationship
yeah because a lot of times we're just
like retelling stories of our own lives
and like giving our opinions on
um whether it's like a fan submitted
question about their relationship
or how we feel about dealing with like
jealousy whereas
before it was um like you said a curated
compilation of clips to portray what the
relationship was
like you know what i mean and so it left
so much space for assumptions
and um having people make
uh just claims about what the
relationship was what it wasn't what
this meant what this didn't mean
and i think with the podcast it's just a
totally different conversation a totally
different dynamic of being you know
quote-unquote public
yeah yeah i guess my i would add to that
is i think that there's still this weird
thing left over from the fact that we're
the first generation that grew up for
the most part with cell phones
in our hands that had cameras and
it's not like we're you know a few years
away from most marriages being the
the 15 people that are in your town that
happens to be within your age group it's
like
you're going to date you're going to
meet people you're going to fall in love
you're going to fall out of love there's
going to be pictures
and there's going to be opinions about
the pictures that exist on the internet
forever from other people
and that should not impact the way that
you look at each other and i think it's
this weird jealousy thing that
guys in particular guys who are
listening are really bad at
trying to play this weird powerful yeah
but you said this to this person you
said this
girls i can i can listen i i think it's
i think i just think
like a lot of guys that just play this
weird game of just like trying to make
people feel bad because they used to be
happy which i think is ridiculous
right right and and because there was a
snapshot of that moment in time when
they were happy
okay if someone made you happy and i
just think that like that will i think
gen z will be much better at it than we
are and i think it'll continue to get
better
i think we're at peak um not knowing how
to handle that
i also think that gen z could get worse
i don't know if i agree with that
sentiment like i was like
sending nudes to like their whole entire
contact list like it is [ __ ]
shocking yeah they have no idea what
it's like to call up your crush
on a phone and have their parents answer
and ask to talk to them
they'll never have that experience
someone pick up the second phone that's
on the same phone line yeah and look
they're like who's there the
uh yeah i feel do you guys have because
you are so
um you're involved in tech and lauren
your whole career is online
do when you guys hang out with each
other do you try to put your phones down
or they're kind of like unspoken rules
with you guys in like social media
um i mean i think we do a pretty i don't
think we've ever come to a point where
we're like okay like we have to make
solid boundaries of like no phone time
um yeah i think we both
decompress some really similarly um at
the end of the day where we just like
uh watch our show have second screen
experience where we're just like sending
dog photos to each other while just like
decompressing from the day but i mean we
don't have any trouble going to dinner
or being in the hot tub and not being on
our phone
um yeah that's just like we've never
really struggled with that so i never
feel like there was a time where we had
to be like okay
boundaries here are the rules and i
would never i would never post something
about her that she wouldn't post about
herself if that makes sense
doesn't matter what she posts about me
to agree because like you know what it
is but like on the flip side
you can't post something that is
off-brand for her
and especially like a casual environment
yeah you respect her brand as much as
you respect her as a partner that's huge
the okay here's a question what would
you tell your 21 year old self
you know nothing yeah you know nothing
you know
literally nothing um i feel like
especially when you're young and i want
to say it's this is like more high
school age but just like
everything every problem feels so big
and
not to say that your problems get bigger
like as you age
but they do but they kind of do yeah
i know so i mean it's just like every
every
bad week that you've ever had you've
always made it through and
um yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] is gonna continue
to
yeah i would basically if i really have
one sentence i would try and convey some
point of like
don't be afraid to be vulnerable
vulnerable to people
um who have
even who have wronged you to a point
where just like don't be afraid of like
just being the bigger person
earlier because like that like that
weird toxicity of just like throwing
just like oh they wronged me or i'm mad
at them i don't talk to them like that
is
exhausting yep yeah it takes a lot of
energy
i had a lot of that for a lot of years
so i'd like to have done that
you've maxed out on the pettiness yeah
okay last question for you guys what has
been your most awkward moment together
oh awkward moment together
hmm or maybe it was in the beginning of
the the
the courtship um
hmm oh i mean we
um i
share a handful of mutual friends with
my ex and
so there was a point where we all went
to a few parties that
um both ex and jeremy had to attend
and so at the beginning that was awkward
but i think they both honestly um kudos
to both them for doing such a great job
of like kind of
smoothing the uh not the tension but
just the
the awkwardness of of just what the
situation was yeah he um
and we've talked about it he messed up
pretty bad um
at one party in particular and i say
that because
his apology was everything that
it needed to be in the sense that i
respected him more for the fact that
like he was upset
i've been that i've been i can't i
cannot judge him for being upset and
acting out
his apology at the time that it was was
so
genuine that it honestly made everything
else afterwards completely smooth
right and that and that smooth things
over for when we had to be at um
you know shared events or parties yeah
that's huge that's a very awkward thing
to confront
but also very huge when you can make it
at least tolerable
and manageable for everyone around you
yeah
yeah but it doesn't have to be beautiful
he loves the awkwardness dig into it
okay guys this has been super fun before
we wrap up completely
um we love to give our guests a little
gift for making time for us so i believe
melissa has emailed you
a personalized fortune cookie oh my god
is for the both of you um that you're
welcome to open and share with the rest
of us
oh my god okay mine is your mom's listen
to every episode of wow until nine
that's it that's the fortune yeah
that's your shared fortune you guys and
i know you think your mom's blocked
but i feel like she's
exposed uh this is so fun you guys thank
you so much for making time to talk to
me
can you tell everyone that doesn't know
where they can find you online where
they can listen to the podcast when they
can listen
et cetera et cetera yeah promo take it
away youtube.com
wildtill9 um every tuesday at
uh what time do we have alone
i'm doing a specific yeah really good
job
every tuesday on every platform for
streaming and audio so if you just start
on the way to work pop it in spotify
apple all the places i will say that uh
the the youtube the youtube portion of
it is a is a richer experience we
actually got a couple dm this last week
of people being like hey could you guys
stop like
making it sound so fun on the video i
know i saw that nothing else
so like if you guys could like stop
making it so obvious that i'm missing
out i'm like
okay sure sure i mean but also the kind
of stuff you guys talk about you want to
see the facial expressions
associated it's a richer experience for
sure yeah
totally and where can people find you
guys separately if they don't know
um youtube.comlorediy and same on all
the socials
i'll just find her you'll find me like
oh
always the supportive boyfriend thank
you guys so much
guys go listen a while till nine you'll
learn all about things like stuck
porn and etc it's a really
i've learned a lot a lot as you can tell
i'll see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music